a Dallas real-estate agent is on life
support with brain damage this morning
after traveling to Mexico for plastic
surgery Laura Aviles family says she
went to a clinic in Ciudad Juarez last
month for several procedures including a
nose job and breast implant replacement
but before those procedures actually
began there were major complications and
a Warner is here with the risks Aviles
family is now warning others about and a
good morning good morning we spoke to a
prosecutor in Mexico who is now handling
an investigation into the Rhino center
or Laura Avila was treated no formal
charges have been filed but the clinic
has been raided now Laura's family is
back in the u.s. and they say they want
justice we don't want this to happen to
anybody else
andrey k cruz says he was at the rhino
center in Ciudad Juarez last month when
his healthy fiance Laura Avila went in
for plastic surgery eight hours later
doctors said there was a problem the
only thing that they told me was that
they had to take her to the hospital
because that the anesthesia wasn't
wearing off and they did not know why I
just said to myself this this isn't
happening like this can't happen
Angie Avila is Laura's sister she says
doctors at the Mexican hospital where
her sister was transferred told them the
Rhino center put the anesthesia in the
wrong place in Laura's spine that her
brain swelled her kidneys failed and she
went into cardiac arrest
because of the damage her brain suffered
she'll never be our Laura again Laura's
fiance says he had researched the clinic
and found positive reviews online and
Angie says they have family in Mexico
and often crossed the border to visit
from El Paso growing up it sounds crazy
to say oh they went to another country
but to us you know it it's it's home
it's familiar a 20-17 study estimated
nearly one-and-a-half million Americans
were expected to travel outside the US
for medical care in Mexico procedures
can cost anywhere between forty and
sixty five percent less than in the u.s.
Laura's family estimates her procedures
were somewhere around $8,500 people are
speaking alternatives Joseph Woodman is
the CEO of patience Beyond Borders the
oversight in countries like Mexico isn't
up to the same standards as it is in the
United States text messages provided by
Laura's family allegedly between her and
a doctor at the Rhino Center show Laura
did have reservations about the
procedures on August 25th dr. Judith
Hernandez wrote you will get a mix of
sedation and blocking Laura later
responded I'm sorry but I don't
understand what sedation and blocking is
and I'm concerned because I'm very
nervous
it's sedation Hernandez responded don't
worry
never in my life did I imagine that we
would get to El Paso and they would tell
us she suffered severe global brain
damage last week Laura was transferred
from the hospital in Mexico to El Paso
where she is currently on life support
her family says they want the Rhino
Center to be held responsible as long as
my heart is beating I will make sure
that they pay for what they did you know
and and this can't happen to anybody
else and her family has to decide very
soon whether to pull life-support and we
tried calling the Rhino center several
times asking for comment but as soon as
we said we were from CBS News they hung
up on us click yeah it so sad to hear
her sister say she'll never be our Laura
again so what can people do to ensure
that a medical procedure abroad will be
safe well I think it's very difficult
the second story we've done on plastic
surgery in Mexico you know they will
tell you for one thing the American
College of Surgeons recommends that you
go to an internationally accredited
institution it does not appear the Rhino
Center was internationally accredited
they also recommend that you see a
surgeon and an anesthesiologist who are
certified through a process equivalent
to what's in the US but I think it's
very tough to figure that out really in
Mexico thank you Anna